[Musique]
où
american heureux de vous retrouver notre
invité principal ce soir c'est pierre
moscovici bonsoir
alors
pierre moscovici comment ça va moi
personnellement bien la dernière fois
qu'on vous a vu à la télé c'était pas
terrible c'est le dimanche soir des
européennes
mais c'était un mauvais pas l'arrêt les
éditions un peu hagard un peu lendemain
de cuite qua non j'aurais pas dit ça
parce que j'ai pas été surpris outre
mesure alors on a beaucoup dit ce soir
là que vous n'étiez pas rasé mais
martine aubry non plus on n'a pas fait
tout un
alors est ce que tu es le plus énervant
soir là c'était d'avoir fait 16% ou le
sourire de xavier bertrand
la france se dit que je déteste pas du
tout mais c'est ce qu'ils pensent lit
tellement sur son visage mais ça le rend
sympathique il faut
alors pierre en p1 nous serons tous les
deux nous parlons de vous de vos
origines de votre engagement politique
puisque vous êtes
socialiste c'est courageux sa simple
socialiste
quand on regarde votre coiffure on voit
vous n'êtes ni aubryste ni royaliste
plutôt fabusien non non pas du tout
alors je sais que j'ai une tête de
famille en plus c'est un peu la même
corpulence et même teinte où ça met pas
du tout en fait le seul socialiste au
kivu rouler aujourd'hui c'est vous non
je roule pour tous les socialistes c'est
vrai que je n'ai plus aujourd'hui de
patrons comme j'ai pu avoir avec lionel
jospin en 2000 strauss kahn et donc par
ailleurs j'ai maintenant un âge où il
faut arrêter de rouler pour les autres
c'est vrai où on ne peut pas être un
éternel lieutenant ils sont plus là mais
voilà brûlé pour vous voilà
alors en p2 nous recevrons deux nouveaux
invités pour commenter avec nous
l'actualité de la semaine christine
kelly membre du conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel vous souvenez de la
polémique avec christine kelly on
l'accusé de d'avoir été nommée au csa
parce qu'elle ait fait un livre sur la
vie de françois fillon est alors elle a
découvert que personne s'était intéressé
à françois fillon avant elle en fait et
quand elle écrit un bouquin l'a compris
pourquoi y at il eu un tome 2 non
il est en forme toujours en p2 nous
accueillerons alexis brézet directeur de
la rédaction du figaro magazine
alexis nous expliquera à quel point
c'est dur de faire un journal
d'actualités que les gens lisent six
mois plus tard chez le docteur
en p3 après le zapping guillon nous
accueillerons notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir laurent fignon pour son
livre nous étions jeunes et insouciants
chez grasset laurent fignon qui nous
révélera qui va gagner le tour de france
cette année comme laboratoire
pharmaceutique
un
très grand amateur de vélo ah bon oui
absolument je crois que je peux citer à
peu près tous les vainqueurs du tour 89
89 c'est pas greg lemond oui bravo
l'émission
on se porte
[Musique]
alors pierre moscovici re bonsoir vous
êtes ici ce soir dans le cadre de
l'opération faites quelque chose pour la
gauche adoptez un socialiste
donc avant de vous faire adopter on va
faire plus ample connaissance avec vous
vous êtes le fils de serge moscovici
dont j'ai longtemps lui les papiers dont
le nouvel observateur chercheurs de
réputation internationale qui est né en
roumanie où après avoir été victime des
fascistes la fameuse garde de fer il a
été interné ensuite par les nazis et
puis quand les communistes sont arrivés
ça s'est pas arrangée il est parti de
roumanie à pieds carrés pas son permis
de conduire et moi non plus et il est
arrivé en france il est resté depuis 62
ans à pied
alors quoi faire a été l'un des pères de
l'écologie politique fondateur des verts
et du fameux journal le sauvage c'était
l'époque de brice lalonde rené dumont de
fournier qu'elle ait créé l'an 01 il a
une originalité mon père lui 84 ans
dimanche dernier ouais et je crois que
c'est le seul verre qui voter socialiste
ah oui je pense qu'il s'est une fois
vous faisait l'amour filial oui vous
n'avez pas été élevé dans le culte de la
social-démocratie encore moins dans le
culte de françois mitterrand puisque
commune et de le dire est une famille
juive on peut être juif et mais françois
mitterrand rue enfin sauf quand on
connaît l'histoire de bousquet et quand
on sait qu'il a eu la francisque pendant
la guerre mitterrand a quand même dit je
regrette de pu le voir oui c'est ça qui
était qui était curieuse lorsqu'il
faisait payant qu'il disait dans les
années 85 86 je n'ai plus pu le voir et
je le regrette marc était sympathique
c'est cette phrase là je crois que
c'était la page 300 voiliers je m'en
souviens que j'étais dans le train en
train de lire ça est vraiment mon sang
n'a fait qu'un tour mais on peut pas non
plus condamner un homme sur une phrase
oui alors dans les années soixante dix
trotskiste êtes proches de la lcr
l'époque c'était krivine et au début des
années 80 vous rencontrer dominique
strauss kahn qui vous convertir la
social-démocratie et était mon prof
l'ena on avait plutôt sympathisé comme
ça et est ce que les filles avaient des
meilleures notes que les autres c'était
un travail de groupe donc tous la même
note alors ensuite il ya le 21 avril un
as et la catastrophe vous êtes effondré
et là vous décidez de prendre vos
affaires en main en fait mais à l'époque
le pen fait 32 % dans ma circonscription
je suis battu j'entame petite traversée
du désert je retourne dans mon corps
d'origine la cour des comptes puis je
suis remonté doucement sur mon cheval
puisque je suis devenu député européen
en 2004 et avec dominique strauss kahn
nous avons créé des clubs à gauche en
europe et puis essayer justement
d'inculquer dans le parti socialiste
l'idée social démocrate il est
réformiste et nous n'avons pas tout à
fait réussi puisque dominique n'a pas
été choisi comme candidat en 2007 et
c'est après 2007 que là je me suis dit
qu'il était temps de prendre en main et
que j'ai candidaté oppose deux premiers
secrétaires de manière
à malraux sillage une image de voûte est
restée à la rochelle quand vous étiez la
terrasse du bistrot avec personne vous
parlait de plus c'est vrai c'était une
cigarette garder
c'est à dire que les autres martine
aubry cambadélis bartolone et c'est lé
déjeuner au resto à côté il m'avait pas
invité en plus certains étaient supposés
santé c'était très sympa mais
aujourd'hui je suis toujours à la table
et eu parfois aride à carrefour du mal
mais je le dis avec toute l'affection
ouais j'ai pour eux mais c'est terrible
le parti socialiste c'est incroyable il
paraît qu'à la dernière réunion rue de
solférino il n'arrivait pas à choisir
quel pizza il voulait
ils ont déposé des motions par pizza
si on se voit tous les deux on va pas
forcément pour la même non plus oui
d'accord mais on n'en parlera pas 100
ans
un gros problème chez les socialistes là
je ne plaisante pas c'est que il ne
s'aime pas assez les alizés et tant que
nous serons comme ça ceux qui souffrent
dans ce pays nous reviendrons parce que
ils en veulent à sarkozy de faire
souffrir mais ils en veulent au parti
socialiste de ne pas trouver les
solutions pour les sortir du sarkozysme
et d'une certaine façon c'est pire c'est
pour ça qu'il ya eu un vote sanction
lors des élections européennes n'ont pas
contre nicolas sarkozy mais contre les
socialistes c'est un comble face à ça
vous vous sentez pousser des ailes vous
dites je fais partie de ceux dont la
candidature aux élections
présidentielles ne serait pas ridicule
écoutez vous savez d'une phrase que
j'aime bien on fera de talent rend lui
ni jambes quand je me contemple rien je
me désole enfin me compare je me console
quand je regarde aujourd'hui l'offre de
présidentiable je me dis c'est
l'évidence que nous n'avons rien qui
s'imposent rien personne tout le monde
se discute et après tout moi je vais
avoir 52 ans j'ai été mise affaires
européennes pendant cinq ans député
européen vice-président du parlement
européen député d'une circonscription 13
ouvrière je suis président de
l'agglomération je passe pas forcément
pour le plus con j'arrive à me causer à
la télé et je crois avoir aussi la
mentalité d'un homme d'état si vous
n'êtes pas mal physiquement
merci
de bien bons dit je me prépare à exercer
des responsabilités d'état je suis
d'accord cette phrase peut paraître
comme ça outrecuidante mais je l'assumé
ouais je me prépare bien sûr et où assa
ou à autre chose qui ont fait pas et
c'est ce que montrent les socialistes
font alors face à cette situation
absolument cauchemardesque pour le parti
socialiste vous avez décidé de lancer
l'idée des primaires c'est à dire que
tous les français seront appelés à voter
ou seulement les membres du parti
socialiste alors toute personne qui se
reconnaît dans les valeurs de la gauche
qui a envie de participer
oui absolument vous allez à la section
socialiste six mois après vous aurez une
sorte de carte d'électeur vous irez
voter et vous choisirez le candidat ou
la candidate socialiste
évidemment si les gens encartés l'ump
arrive en masse ça se verra quand même
et c'est ça que je voulais vous dire si
elle vous pensez pas que les gens de
l'ump ils vont choisir le plus tôt car
ça je pense qu'ils savent c'est désigner
j'ai bien
du tout partir oui loin d'être là plutôt
carte vous êtes sympas et le président
d'afrique c'est pas la mieux quand c'est
ça vous engage un bon pour ma part je ne
suis pas encore dans ce choix là je
savais pourquoi proposer des primaires
c'est plus important peut-être encore
peu de dire comment c'est parce qu'à
l'évidence le parti socialiste lui même
n'arrive plus à réduire la création
présidentielle on a peu de militants qui
ressemble pas la société française je
les aime ces militants socialistes mais
ils savent eux-mêmes qu'il faut s'ouvrir
loin qu'il faut ouvrir les portes et les
fenêtres et je crois que ce serait
tellement mieux de faire comme aux
etats-unis c'est-à-dire d'avoir un
million deux millions trois millions de
personnes qui vont choisir un candidat
ou une candidate d'ailleurs parlons de
barack obama si barack obama avait été
choisi par les militants du parti
démocrate qui l'auraient pas été josé
abad et choisissez qu'elle s'était
étonnée je reste bien sûr alors voilà
donc désormais il y aura au parti
socialiste des moscovici sts ça c'est
embêtant certains maladies
moscovici doré un peu
alors
j'avais déjà un courant qui s'appelle
besoin de gauche je dois de gauche brûlé
par les besoins des lecteurs c'est
plutôt ça le problème c'est la même
chose a eu d'accord et j'ai jamais pensé
que le parti suisse pourrait disparaître
peut-être que dans 20 ans disent y aura
plus de parti socialiste basque et sur
le parti socialiste pour lui maintenant
c'est vraiment se rénover ou mourir et
la présidentielle de 2012 dans ce cadre
là est très importante si on n'est pas
capable en 2012 présenté une offre
politique qui soit consistante si on
reste dans nos bisbilles dans nos
divisions et c'est non seulement on sera
puni mais derrière je crois qu ont
disparu à 27 ans il y aura autre chose
doit les ours blancs qu'elle et sociale
qui vont disparaître
on fait de non recevoir qui sync
si braisé
dentelle avec nos actualités
[Musique]
la revend son intérieur nous sommes
toujours en compagnie de pierre
moscovici
et nous recevons christine kelly motion
et avec 6 braisé
soir alors christine kelly bonsoir vous
êtes depuis janvier membre du conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel le csa
vous faites partie des sages donc est-ce
que vous avez été sages cette semaine
depuis le 24 janvier 0,1 complètement
changé sa fille devenue très simple très
sage
leurs parents étaient enseignants vous
avez passé votre jeunesse au au lamentin
vous avez fait une licence de maths
physique alors physique je comprends
mais en maths est ce que vous êtes bonne
en amour un plus un égale trois oui
c'est vrai ça va alors ensuite j'ai fait
des petits jobs hôtesse de l'air etc et
puis les médias est votre première
émission c'était karibe scop une
émission d'actu sur les caraïbes ce qui
se passait dans les caraïbes sur une
chaîne qui s'appelait archipel 4 ensuite
j'ai l'air est faux et là vous vous
dites quand même il faudrait que je
fasse des progrès en journalisme et très
courageusement vous avez fait l'institut
de journalisme de bordeaux j'étais
animatrice et je me suis dit que pour
durer de mende dans le métier il va
falloir que je devienne journal histoire
et au moment où ça marchait très bien
pour moi j'ai tout laissé tomber pour
mort fermé et m'asseoir sur les bancs de
lassitude des croiseurs
isoler une raison parce qu'après il ya
une frange 3 et puis elle s'y est
parallèlement vous avez fait des livres
alors un livre sur l' affaire flactif
d'affaires du grand bornand un livre sur
le footballeur william gallas
est un livre sur françois fillon qui
s'appelle le secret et l'ambition alors
c'était terrible parce que j'ai trahi
six mois sur ce bouquin travail acharné
vous dormiez plus vous avez perdu la
notion du temps vous avez même pensé à
aller voir un psychothérapeute à un
moment c'est si dur que ça de trouver
quelque chose à dire sur fion
c'est si dur que ça de faire un livre
sur qui tu avec sur quelqu'un qui
refusait que j'étais sur lui et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé
vraiment décrire sur lui oui ont refusé
j'ai écrit sur lui et plus jamais
enquêté sur le terrain la télé etc et
effectivement j'ai compris pourquoi un
peu de personnes s'était lancé dans la
vente au coût alors parce que c'est pas
facile de trouver l'information parce
qu'il fait barrage il fait barrage vous
ai trouvé des trucs un peu il avait fait
une manifestation chez les jésuites ce
qui n'était jamais vu parce qu'il
s'était jamais vu enfin oui j'ai lu j'ai
eu des syriens ça et oui pour lui
c'était avant lui et oui c'est ça c'est
le côté ray sur le côté il avait changé
de côté
il avait une mairie un jour il avait lui
même ligne évidemment vous avez vendu
combien avec 8 soit sur fion très 10010
vous savez quand même je suis arrivé à
vendredi
alors maintenant c'est vrai que vous
attaquez une biographie de nicolas
dupont aignan non
non pas encore
alors donc après ce livre sur fion c'est
là que le 23 janvier dernier xiti en
italie et vous recevez un coup de fil de
gérard larcher le président du sénat et
qui vous demande de prendre un avion
pour paris aux frais de la république
sans vous dire pourquoi et à la descente
d'avion c'est incroyable on dirait un
film et la descente d'avion une voiture
officielle qui vous attend qui vous
emmène avait visé et avait visé il ya
larcher et sarkozy qui lui disent est ce
que voulait faire partie du csa c'est
une histoire incroyable alors c'est pas
tout à fait ça il ya eu bien ça sais tu
ce mignon
voici la véritable histoire du 23
janvier bon d'accord juste avant de
partir d'abord en vacances en italie
j'avais déjà reçu un coup de fil du
cabinet de gérard larcher que je n'avais
jamais rencontré de ma vie pour
m'inviter à être nommée au csa si ça
m'intéressait je me suis plongé dans les
dossiers etc je suis parti parce que
c'était prévu et de là bas effectivement
les choses continuer à avancer le
président gérard larcher m'a demandé est
ce que je peux rentrer franchement j'ai
payé mon billet d'avion aller retour
et quand j' en ai discuté avec gérard
larcher j'ai d'abord demandé pourquoi
moi il m'a expliqué que mon parcours
l'intéressé et il s'est dit qu'il
voulait pas nommer quelqu'un comme lé
profil habituel les énarques et cetera
il voulait quelqu'un qui connaissait
vraiment l'audiovisuel comme le fait que
je sois dans l'outre-mer côté minorités
visibles
il m'a pas dit ça comme ça en tout cas
comme minorité l'isi vous êtes très joli
est-ce que je suis visible ce convoi
est ce qu'on peut dire ça aux gens du
siège est ce qu'on peut dire qu'ils sont
jolis fait que la première fois que
quelqu'un de jolis au csa peut dire
aussi
joker alors voilà donc sarko vous dis ce
soir à faudra passer me voir plus
souvent vous êtes retourné jamais
j'avais
c'était pas un soir c'était le midi
drôle oui je suis allé lorsque j'ai été
convoqué
alors la face à cet engouement
évidemment la presse étrangère comprend
pas et vous présente comme la sarcosine
you babe la nouvelle nana que sarko
voilà vous trouvez pas qu'il ya un truc
qui cloche en tant que présentatrice
télé
j'ai un haut de maillot de bain
en tant que journaliste josh d'un
journal télévisé j'aurais très bien pu
avoir des photos en topless c'est vrai
bah oui et puis comme ça vous auriez
attaquer les paparazzades
voilà alors vous voilà donc c'est ça
c'est dur de surveiller ce qui se passe
et la télévision ça oblige à la
regardais déjà ce qu'il veut pas tous
les jours non le csa c'est bien mais il
ya beaucoup de boulot et le csa c'est
des nominations au conseil
d'administration ces dérèglements
sarkozy nous a quand même piquer votre
bolide numéro acte de nous mais les
patrons de l'audiovisuel public quand
même
c'était un non mais c'est vrai
il faudrait il faudrait connaître quelle
que soit l'indépendance du csa quelle
que soit sa sagesse tout de même
l'exécutif avait un pouvoir assez
prépondérant avant la limite il est plus
facile de novaes des amis avant
qu'aujourd'hui mais sarkozy aime bien
faire ça non mais pour ce plus qui sont
ses amis finalement il faut pas trop
être ump avec lui sinon sa pile à des
amis on assure ne pas voir une scène
hôtel non mais tous je tiens vraiment à
dire que la nomination du président de
france télévisions franchement par
rapport à eau puis s'en fout et au
travail qui a à faire tous les jours
franchement ce n'est strictement rien
alors c'est quoi les avantages d'être
aussi ça faisait le portable de cauet
par exemple
justement j'ai rien à voir ou bien celui
de thierry henry ça me fait drôle d'être
avec un nom du csa sur le plateau j'ai
l'impression d'être un prof avec un
inspecteur d'académie
je fais gaffe à ce que je dis c'est pas
votre mordant habituel ballon mais bien
sûr ce que nous
espérons c'est quelque chose qu'on
rigolait de nouveau chez vous
on
[Musique]
je note oui
bien sûr mon plateau pour m'interdire de
signer
ou fumé pabx ou non ne peut pas boire
non plus avant moi je me suis mis à la
télé lanvin 2008 par exemple on buvait
comme des trous maintenant on peut plus
boire à l'antenne merci
et oui oui
c'est quoi
d'abord une lettre ensuite lettres de
mise en mise en garde lettre de mise en
demeure procès de d'ascension et
attention au lever la sanction peut
aller jusqu'à 3% du chiffre d'affaires
de la chaîne relâcher
si les connais pas
et vous pensez que les pétards ça va
rester interdits sur les plateaux allez
quoi les qualcomm j'ai pas encore vu tes
ni tester donc je ne sais pas mais je ne
savais pas ça en fait vous n'êtes pas là
encore non mais bien sûr ça va rester
interdites
bien rares alexis brézet re bonsoir vous
êtes directeur de la rédaction du figaro
magazine
vous êtes ici ce soir pour convaincre
pierre moscovici donc que nicolas
sarkozy est un homme formidable et qu'il
devrait rejoindre le gouvernement
faut essayer il est touché à la partie
sociale je crois qu'il a des envies
c'est au parti socialiste qui font qu'il
n'a pas tellement vide ni intérêt par le
gouvernement moi je suis pas un
antisarkozyste primaire je crois que
nicolas sarkozy était un chef politique
d'une qualité exceptionnelle mais
franchement j'ai aucune sympathie ni
pour sa politique ni une partie rend
pour sa personne et donc vraiment
l'ouverture c'est pas pour moi parce que
vous êtes jeunes en fait un mec comme
kouchner il est tellement vieux que s'il
y va pas avec sarko il a jamais alors là
oui bien sûr c'est un réflexe dont
j'espère être prémunie à tout jamais
dans il ya ça il y en a d'autres comme
besson c'est pas le cas c'est encore
autre chose et c'est une mentalité et
une conviction franchement moi il ya une
j'ai déjà été ministre en cinq ans c'est
une frustration que j'ai pas et si je
devais un jour y retourner ce serait
avec la gauche pas exact
vu l'état du ps si vous voulez alors
écouter ce qu'on va faire on va vous
demander de dire du bien des gens dont
vous dites du mal et finalement dans
votre journal on va faire une interview
fan 2
m
avec 6 qu'est ce que vous aimez le plus
chez ségolène royal d'abord les belles
et ensuite politiquement elle a eu des
vraies intuition et des vrais intuition
pendant la campagne elle a senti un truc
alors de façon un peu de temps en temps
il rationnel et désordonnée mais elle a
senti un truc c'est que les français
voulaient de la transgression sarkozy
l'avait compris bayrou l'avait confirmé
c'est pas un hasard si ces trois-là y
était donc je pense que elle a un
instinct politique qu'est ce que vous
aimez chez martine aubry cède plus dur
là
je dirais que la du courage
je pense que ses débuts au ps ont pas
été bon et que la campagne a pas été
bonne tout n'est pas de sa faute ouais
mais que fait une bonne campagne qu'il
fallait faire campagne sur des thèmes
européens qu'elle n'a pas fait qu'elle
n'a pas su associer les gens qu'il
fallait que je n'étais pas trop de
pagaille elle sait ça mais quand elle le
dit maintenant qu'elle était trop dans
la dénonciation est passé une
appropriation elle n'a changé elle a
essayé de changer de pied tout à la fin
la campagne mais c'était trop tard vous
vous avez dit en parlant de martine
aubry
il faut qu'elles bougent vite et fort on
est calme et risque bien qu'elle fasse
bouger le parti socialiste a beau jeu
vite et fort et sociale dans cette
espèce d'immobilisme délétère je note
quand même que dès que vous demandez
qu'est ce qu'on aime chez tel ou tel
c'est d'abord le critère physique qui
ressort et c'est dommage
bien hors change est un peu tu vas faire
avec vous maintenant qu'est-ce que vous
aimez chez christian estrosi
la mèche oui janvie par rapport à ce
moment que ça d'avoir une messe comme
estrosi ou jeffries et mois
plus tôt les cheveux comme ça chez
balkany vous aimez quoi chez voile que
ni franchement prolonge un bon jeu du
mal à trouver assez c'est à la belle
image de la politique mais c'est un
grand pote de sarkozy qu'est ce que vous
aimez chez besancenot vous qui étiez un
fan de krivine à l'époque j'aime bien
qu'il aime krivine puisque moi j'ai
trouvé arrivée d'un type extrêmement
sympathique drôle et c'est besancenot
beaucoup beaucoup moins drôle
besancenot c'est quand quelqu'un d'assez
rigide 1 c'est pas marrant et je crois
que les français
après avoir eu comme ça une espèce de
sympathie pour le poste à laon sont un
peu revenus parce que le côté
systématiquement contre l'eire dur ça
n'a pas convaincu d'avoir fait un
mauvais si la ferme aux médias télés 3d
dauphins
au début on disait vas faire 8 9 10%
puis finalement et il est allé trop dur
en début de campagne notamment avec les
histoires de manif à l'otan de même il
est allé trop trop dans le trou dans le
dur et finalement c'est mélenchon qui
tirait sur le pillage sont pas besoin
ouais ouais ou line et bien mélanger
l'eau chaude et très vite qu'est ce que
vous préférez sénat n'ont jamais
champion il est très élaborée serbe puis
de culture et puis c'est un tribun c'est
un tribun c'est une petite iem la
politique et c'est une gauche alors que
pierre parce que s'y trouvent peut-être
un peu à l'ancienne mais qui parle parce
que parce qu'elle est enracinée le
peuple est plus compliqué que ça va vite
si boisé parce que si le peuple voter
systématiquement pour front de gauche
ils l'auraient pas fait s'ils % et donc
c'est il suffit pas d'avoir des accents
comme ça de tryba pour être près du
peuple peuple c'est le métro à six
heures c'est tout le monde il ya de tout
qu'est ce que vous aimez bien chez
fillon vous c'est un homme politique de
très bonne tenue il est à sa place à
matignon simplement il ya une chose
qu'on ne connaît pas suffisamment on le
voit à l'assemblée nationale c'est un
type extrêmement dur ça c'est pas le bon
garçon gentil c'est un politique dure
probablement un des plus fermés de la
droite c'est le vrai conservateurs c'est
un dur de dur et souvent quelle question
d'une réforme qui se pose c'est plutôt
sarkozy quelle image de dur qui pour
dire bon ben je rédigeais et sion qu'il
veut aller jusqu'au bout bon ça se
confirmait on se rappelle de la réforme
des retraites en 2003 lorsqu'il ya eu je
sais pas combien de milliers de
manifestants dans la rue il a été sur 1
20 heures d'un plateau télé pour dire
non à la rue il a été très dur ce
jour-là et réforme de l'éducation où il
a essayé de tenir jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
mans où chirac l'a dit mais bon tu es
d'accord tu lâches il a en lui un côté
teigneux mais vraiment teigneux alors
est ce que j'aime ou j'aime pas ouais un
peu des deux voilà on continue notre
commentaire de l'actualité de la semaine
avec les infos de blako 1
en iran il ya tous les jours des
manifestations mais dans le fond à quoi
bon pour la population contester les
résultats de l'élection bon d'accord la
majorité a voté moussavi et ahmadinejad
reste au pouvoir enfin pour ce que ça
change pense quand ils rentrent c'est
pas le président qui décide de tout le
chef le vrai c'est qu'à menez le guide
suprême et lui il n'a jamais été élu
pourtant il a tous les pouvoirs y
compris celui de viry président obama a
prévenu moussavi ou ahmadinedjad pour
lui c'est kif kif bourricot soi-disante
moussavi un modéré en attendant il a été
premier ministre de l'ayatollah khomeiny
et il demande à ses partisans de crier
tous les soirs à la barre par la fenêtre
alors pour ça change vraiment en iran
faudra un peu plus que des
manifestations faudra ben faudra
carrément une vraie évolution
[Musique]
mise en image de julien gracq voilà ce
qu'il faut dire évidemment c'est que
mousavi s'est pas laigle ba les arts
quand ils ferment a explosé démocrates
contre les méchants comment est-ce que
les gens mais c'est quand même pas la
même chose non plus non plus mais c'est
vrai que c'est une élection pour pas
grand chose un rapport par exemple à la
main tendue de barack obama via ce qui
mit fin à traiter le dossier nucléaire
iranien par la force par le gros bâton
comme des bouche moussavi répondait ok
il tend la main je lui tends way et
ahmadinejad ne le fait pas ce qui je
pense est la raison pour laquelle le
guide de la révolution khamenei n'a pas
consenti à l'élection de moussavi du
point de vue la politique internationale
c'est
quand même assez différent sur la
question d'israël malgré tout moussavi
quand même moins anti israélien va vite
que l'autre donc ça changerait oui mais
voilà avant donc non ça changerait pas
mal de choses obama dont on disait il va
voir qu'un guide dans sa politique c'est
des droits de l'homme là on le voit
quand même il est quand même très
prudent mais ici on se tape pas de même
il est déjà derrière et on va alors
qu'on est en train d'essayer de renouer
des trucs délirants mais c'est pas la
peine de tout casser maintenant donc on
on le voit bien qu'il a poussé son vice
président joe biden pour taper et lui
il fait part de son souci mais va pas
plus loin il ya un truc dans cette
histoire le seul qui est content c'est
dieudonné sa liste a fait 18 % à téhéran
non mais sérieusement cette histoire
d'âme à ninja de là vous n'avez pas peur
qu'il envoie une bombe sur israël un
iran nucléaire c'est très très dangereux
c'est donc pour ça qu'il faut essayer de
résoudre sa part la main tendue en tous
les cas si l'on la bombe ça peut être
une troisième guerre mondiale non vous
croyez pas effectivement israël entrera
dans la danse ça fragilise tout
l'équilibré stérile et ses menaces et
manor à la bombe atomique iranienne de
toute façon si un moment donné l'iran
atteint ce qu'on appelle le seuil
nucléaire comme s'ils passent d'une
façon ou d'une autre soit directement
soit via israël ils taperont mais alors
cette base française à abou dhabi il est
ce que vous pensez pas que si abou dhabi
est attaqué on est lié par des accords
qui vont nous obliger à rentrer dans la
guerre et la question c'est
effectivement pour quelle stratégie à
quelles stratégies réponse atteint pour
les autres débilités parce que vous
savez les accords qui ont été signés par
sarkozy avec abu dhabi les accords de
réciprocité militaires non non je suis
pourtant nombre de la commission des
affaires étrangères vous le savez pas
non moi j'étais président d'une
commission d' enquête sur la libération
des infirmières olivier pas pu voir
cécile est un gars j'ai pas pu voir
cécilia mais j'ai eu aussi beaucoup de
mal à voir les accords ouais oui c'est à
dire que là si sarkozy s'est engagé à
défendre
abou dhabi en cas d' attaque iranienne
vous le savez par personne les accords
de défense saab sont pas du tout soumis
au parlement n'ont pas toujours pas
toujours et si vous demandez à le savoir
si demain vous dites maintient
finalement je voudrais savoir je suis
député de la république je voudrais
savoir quel accord nous lie à abou dhabi
pourrait le savoir ça je vais le
demander ma demande et le jeu des
comédiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je sais pas je suis assez
inquiet parce que je vois que netanyahou
quand même il ne met pas du sien non
c'est à dire qu' on essaie d'imaginer l'
inverse c'est à dire qu'on demande à
israël d'avoir un état démilitarisé
d'avoir une absence d' appareil
répressif n'est pas combat de contrôle
de son espace aérien se passait rien n'y
pas de liberté diplomatique voilà voilà
ce que netanyahu demande à la palestine
alors il ya un point positif dans cette
affaire là c'est que c'est la première
fois que nous tiennent you parle d'un
état palestinien mais ce qui veut dire
qu'à un moment donné quand même il
pourrait assouplir son attitude mais en
même temps la façon dont il en parle est
absolument inacceptable et c'est là on
voit d'ailleurs que la tâche d'obama est
très compliqué quand vous avez des
partenaires compliqué comme à rosny et
jade et une et agneaux que je ne compare
tout de même pas mais enfin attention
des durs tous les domaines de trafigura
il a des gens pas facile qui devra d'une
façon ou d'une autre soient convaincre
je dois faire plier avec vous si c'est
facile on dit n'importe quoi donc c'est
normal que ça tourne mal mais en soit on
est en train de se rendre compte qu'il
suffit pas de tenir des propos sensés
équilibré mais sert que des gens qui ne
veulent pas s'entendre sans poser
réellement donc j'ai des ventes je pense
en même temps que la situation politique
en israël et pas durable n'est pas
tenable ce gouvernement est un
gouvernement qui ne représente pas bien
la société israélienne lézina kahn donne
trois milliards de dollars chaque année
à israël est ce qu'ils arrêteraient de
les donner si netanyahou ne respecte pas
non un minimum la réponse est non parce
que israël et les états unis sont liés
par une amitié indéfectible et puis
d'autre part attention il faut comparer
ce qui est comparable ahmadinejad c'est
quand même un type qui révisionniste
ouais c'est bien négationnistes et les
conditions de son élection font très
douteuse le régime est un régime
démocratique israël est une grande
démocratie est ce que notre sage a
quelque chose à ajouter
non non je pense que barack obama
on ne peut pas imaginer un seul instant
que barack obama n'est pas sa stratégie
sur ces deux dossiers l'iran et israël
bien avant d'être élu c'est impensable
inch'allah
on passe aux infos de blako 2
[Applaudissements]
ça y est c'est l' alerte maximum pour la
grippe a le messe a décrété le niveau 6
bon en france on en est qu'au niveau 5
mais la situation est grave le
gouvernement devrait dépenser un
milliard d'euros pour fabriquer 100
millions de doses de vaccin d'ici
l'automne en attendant il a peur se
propage plus vite que le virus cette
semaine près de toulouse une dizaine
d'enfants ont été hospitalisés et selon
certaines prévisions la grippe a pour
être joué trente mille personnes en
france cet idéal non mais vous vous
rendez compte trente mille morts c'est
le nombre d'enfants qui meurent du
paludisme en afrique tous les quinze
jours à bas et que voulez-vous un tous
les enfants naissent libres et égaux
mais quand il s'agit de mourir les
africains restent vachement avantage
[Applaudissements]
jaegli à est arrivé à toulouse où ils
l'ont rebaptisé la grippe a comme
voilà enfin le plus bizarre quand même
c'est que c'est des élèves de 6e b qui
ont eu la grippe a
ça n'est sûrement pas et 133 cas en
france et c'est beaucoup quand même
ouais enfin il paraît que ce toulouse ça
va mieux là ils sont sortis mon pouvoir
retourner à l'école pour se faire
agresser à coups de couteau
par doc de cette histoire
gens se focalisent sur le mot de
pandémie on se dit pas parce que c'est
une pandémie si une épidémie en plus
grave voilà en fait c'est pas une
épidémie en plus grave c'est une
épidémie en plus grand or là apparemment
cette grippe là elle va être énorme
touché énormément de monde mais elle
n'est pas plus grave qu'une grippe
saisonnière
il faut trouver le bon vaccin comme tous
les ans il faut trouver le vaccin n'a vu
que saisonnière c'est quand même au
niveau 6 au niveau part parce qu'on
compte le niveau géographique
effectivement il ya 133 cas en france
avec c'est pas non plus la fin du monde
je pense qu'il faut pas du tout
minimiser la grippe a sans être
alarmiste mais une pandémie faut pas
rigoler chez moi j'écoute tout ce que
disent les styles moi je déconne pas
je me mets bien avec le csa bien on
passe aux infos de blako 3
tout le monde critique les dérives du
capitalisme
mais la sécu c'est exactement pareil le
système de retraite par répartition
c'est le même genre d'arnaqué que celle
montée par bernard madoff l'argent versé
au pop art les derniers arrivés permet
de payer ceux qui sont déjà inscrits
depuis longtemps alors bien sûr quand
les anciens deviennent trop nombreux par
rapport aux nouveaux d'un toute la rade
des rails 20 milliards de déficit pour
la sécu cette année 70 milliards à
cumuler les années précédentes ça nous
fait près de 100 milliards à rembourser
et tout ça parce que les vieux refuse de
laisser leur place aux jeunes pourtant
il suffirait d'encourager la
consommation de tabac et d'alcool de
supprimer les limitations de vitesse au
volant et l'autre les comptes sont
équilibrés aa c'est quand même plus
sympa comme solution que de bosser
jusqu'à 67 ans
un enfant sur deux qui naît aujourd'hui
vivra jusqu'à 100 ans oui c'est un
problème je crois que la position
d'hortefeux et filles ont d'ailleurs qui
proposait d'allonger l'âge de la
retraite jusqu'à 67 ans était un ballon
d'essai voire une provocation qui dit à
ses laideurs ce que sera à mon avis le
deuxième partie du quinquennat qui sera
plus dur que la première en réalité mais
nous verrons c'est mon pronostic mais
vous savez les niveau des pensions
baisse la durée de cotisation augmente
et l'âge légal de la retraite doit
rester à 60 ans de toute façon pour
quelqu'un qui cotisent 42 ou 43 ans ben
c'est au delà et donc c'est une
hypocrisie et je crois que c'est une
provocation ok je vous propose est alors
parti socialiste l'a déjà une solution
qui est assez simple c'est que la
meilleur des remèdes c'est l'emploi et
notamment l'emploi des seniors parce que
c'est quand même assez incroyable de
dire qu'on va allonger l'âge de la
retraite l'âge légal alors qu' il ya une
très forte proportion de la population
qui ne travaillent pas 55 ans - et donc
là il ya quand même un chantier social
majeur ça sert à rien de monter l'âge de
retraite si les gens sont mis dehors
donc il faut garder les vieux dans les
boîtes à 55 ans à dieu thierry il va pas
du tout pas du tout pensé que ça peut
disparaître la sécu non non je sais qu
n'est pas mortel mais pour l'un des
financement de la sécu les problèmes
démographiques sont des problèmes
absolument cruciaux et je suis pas
certain qu'on ait ni les uns ni les
autres d'ailleurs les solutions adaptées
mais en même temps parler de l'âge légal
de la retraite le recul à 67 ans à mon
avis n'a pas de sens beaucoup plus
réfléchir à la retraite à la carte à la
retraite au choix les différencier aussi
sur la pénibilité des métiers
oui
ouvriers effectivement des gens comme
nous qui ont des métiers agréable et
sympathique on peut pas dit c'est pas la
même chose à quel âge vous devrez vous
partir en terre 75 à
autre chose dans l'actualité de la
semaine bongo vous avez vu bongo chirac
a déposé un rib sur sa tombe
mais combien de la vengeance est un plat
qui se mange froid parce que j'aimerais
une fois mais c'est regarder quand même
une de ces séances où il ya jean louis
debré au milieu qui détestent sarkozy où
il ya giscard et chirac qui se haïssent
ils commettent un pot et mes temps en
temps ça donne aussi des trucs assez
spéciaux comme la censure d'hadopi la
première séance où les deux centres ev
debré fait le pari qu au bout de dix
minutes ils s'engueulent ray est au bout
de 7 minutes il y a giscard qui commence
jamais quand vous étiez mon premier
ministre et leur l'autre enquête lien et
puis trois minutes après lors de mon
deuxième mandat
chirac c'est un type qui a une carapace
ouais absolument monstrueuse giscard
d'une certaine poésie amazighe plus
sensibles mais tout glisse sur chirac
ouais ouais c'est au nom bien merci à
tous les droits mais aussi alexis on va
vous laisser filer merci d'avoir été
avec lyon nous on se rappelle que david
guion
je suis à laurent fignon aux folies
jeunes et insouciants
chez
m
[Musique]
comme vous le savez on paie 3 nous
recevrons invités du samedi 20 heures ce
soir laurent fignon ménès
pour son livre nous étions jeunes et
insouciants chez grasset toujours en
compagnie de christine kelly
et le pierre moscovici
alors laurent fignon bonsoir vous
resterez dans l'histoire du cyclisme
français comme un des rares à avoir
gagné deux fois le tour de france en 83
et 84 et 11 ans la gueule que vous aviez
à l'époque
et reçoit ici le maillot de leader au
dernier maillot celui intéressés de
laurent sauf du ce premier ministre et
jacques chirac maire de paris
voilà mais vous resterez encore plus
comme celui qu'il a perdu 2,8 secondes à
la dernière étape en 89 voilà vous avez
pas égaler le palmarès de louison bobet
vous raconter tout ça dans un livre qui
paraît cette semaine et vous annoncé
parallèlement votre cancer l'an oui pour
faire le buzz vous êtes champions vont
pas fait exprès ces concours de
circonstances le livre était terminé et
j'ai appris un petit mois après que
j'avais malheureusement cette maladie
que moi si vous propose le pot belge
pour guérir ça vous dit non on croit que
c'est ce que personne n'a jamais essayé
on reconnaît le cycliste
on en parlera à 20 heures en attendant
j'accueille stéphane guillon
mais d'abord le zapping voilà c'était le
zapping avoue stéphane pour la semaine
fillon
[Musique]
on va tirer je veux faire un petit truc
un peu festif pour la dernière donc j'ai
convoqué des artistes voilà pour
commenter la saison
2008-2009 à ma place et on commence avec
le patron le boss guy bedos
[Applaudissements]
pour la gauche c'était une année
pitoyable 16 % aux européennes c'est
plus qu'une défaite sur à clé là quand
on pense que martine aubry est devenu le
premier secrétaire du ps avec seulement
70 voix d'avancé
des bulletins que laurent fabius
probablement photocopier
dans ce temps-là l'autre dingue ségolène
se trémousse zénith en chantant
fraternité fraternité j'en peux plus
autre valls qui tient des propos
racistes
drake je démontre que l'argent des
associations et kouchner qui fricote
avec des dictateurs africains je peux
plus c'est fini j'arrête le vieux clown
s'éclipse dieu dieu
non mais attends attends b2t normal
qu'il soit énervé un guichet un
gaulliste c'est un militant de la
première heure les chamailleries du ps
vis ça très malin puisqu'il à 10 heures
martine aubry c'est résultat depuis
qu'elle est première secrétaire c'est la
bérézina puis toutes ces photos qu'elle
a fait dans gala c'est grotesque à se
faire photographier en train de manger
des moules dans un restaurant lillois
tout ça pour finir à ses fonctions de
l'européenne ça pleurait tu sais non
mais tu sais que c'est très très grave
la cité est et au ps
[Applaudissements]
alors là là on a une saison géniale
thierry michèle alliot-marie qui fait
emprisonner un simple épiciers de tarnac
pour terrorisme vambre du salami est
aussi grave que percuté le world trade
center avec un boeing c'est énorme a
lyon marie faut pas la faire chier des
voitures de police pour arrêter un
chiard de six ans à la sortie de l'école
à côté le président iranien c'est une
petite [ __ ] on montre dans la troisième
dimension si dire ouh la menteuse à
nadine morano entraîne une convocation
au commissariat un papier écrit par
canteloup ou guillon ces tortures direct
on les prend par les pieds on leur coupe
les couillons les écarts tels on touche
au sublime
[Applaudissements]
dames et messieurs bonsoir saison mi
figue mi raisin tout augmente les prix
les loyers le nombre de chômeurs 2 pour
le trou de la sécu à plus de 20
milliards d'euros la seule chose qui
baisse sont mes audiences sur arte - de
80000 spectateurs si je continue à être
un loser je vais peut-être prendre ma
carte du ps comme moscovici
bonsoir
mélange de joie et de tristesse ce soir
puisque l'émission phare de canal + à
nous les terriens achève sa troisième
saison saison injustes et cruelles ou
des bébés fleurs congelé dans des
frigidaires quand un autre plus chanceux
naquit sous les lambris d'un ministère
zohra dati petite fille riche élevé
avenue montaigne et qui dans quelques
jours arpentera tristement avec sa
nounou les ruelles de strasbourg
saison étrange où jacques séguéla
déclara que passé 50 ans un homme sans
rolex avait raté sa vie alors que julien
dray qui en possèdent plusieurs sombre
et quelques jours après saison coquines
ou dsk et berlusconi enchaînèrent les
concours de braguette
exercice périlleux quand on sait qu
edouard stern il laissa la vie trouver
de quatre balles par sa maîtresse alors
qu'il portait une combinaison en latex
tel un vulgaire préservatif
saison meurtrière puisque 228 passagers
en provenance de rio mourut en plein vol
incident technique négligence d'air
france à vingt mille lieues sous les
mers le mystère reste intense
merci thierry merci l'équipe merci au
public
ciani stefan c'était chez damier
hélicéa sur galles
[Musique]
et maintenant on passe à l'invité du
samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
là on finit on re bonsoir publié chez
grasset nous étions jeunes et
insouciants où vous racontez votre
carrière dans le cyclisme amateur et
professionnel pendant les années 80 90
et vous commencez votre bouquin par ce
fameux tour 89 que vous avez perdu à
cause de 8 secondes et c'est très
poignant quand vous racontez ça vous
vous dites c'est des champs elysées
l'avenue du martyr quoi c'est vraiment
ça vous flinguent ce truc là quoi
effectivement c'est dur c'est très dur à
encaisser aujourd'hui on vous dirais
même que ça continue de me poursuivre
ainsi pas complètement abattus chaque
fois qu'on m'en parle mais on en parle
tout le temps les gens vous disent je
vous reconnais vous êtes celui qui a
perdu le tour de vis secondes alors on
vous dit non je suis aussi celui qui en
a gagné deux en même temps oui ça c'est
un peu la mentalité française toujours
des papes est pas forcément des défaites
mais des histoires en tout cas - et
doivent en avoir gagné deux je sais pas
si tout le monde s'en souvenait de ces
lois je préfère que ça oui c'est vrai et
c'est vrai qu'après quand vous faisiez
des courses après ce tour de 89 les gens
sur la route vous disais quand ils
voyaient passer vas-y vas-y tu encore 8
secondes de retard
mais en plus ce n'était pas toujours le
cas la grande révélation du bouquin
c'est que vous êtes dopé laurent laurent
fignon 2p [ __ ] moi le monde s'écrouler
quand j'ai lu ça qui aujourd'hui pensait
que le cyclisme n'avait pas eu de dopage
avant avant l'avant les 98 ouais mais
quand vous regardez les l'histoire du
cyclisme des les frères pélissier ils
avouent qu'ils prennent des produits
parce que c'est trop dur c'est c'est
inhumain donc ça a toujours été comme ça
la seule chose qu'on pourrait me
reprocher c'est de ne pas avoir senti
que c'était de la triche d'être avoir
été pris par mon métier par l'ambiance
du de cette époque-là dire que vous en
fait c'était avant le pot 1 ça vous
c'était les amphétamines la cortisone
les amphétamines étaient contrôlés a
tous les atouts les a toutes les courses
donc ce n'était pas pour les courses
étaient pour les critériums un petit peu
festif on s'amusait le soir avec ça
puisqu'on ne remet pas donc on s'amuse à
la cortisone ou effectivement mais
sachez par exemple qu'aujourd'hui avec
une justification médicale on a le droit
de prendre la cortisone oui quand est ce
que c'était vraiment du dopage
finalement mais on peut se poser la
question et dans la politique et du
dopage aussi sûrement en
tout cas pour ce qui me concerne sortie
du mark je peux pas dire non pas un soda
qui d'énergie ans je prends rien ah
ouais même pas de café on parle beaucoup
de dopage dans le cyclisme pour moi qui
ai fait un livre sur un footballeur
moyen beaucoup intéressé au football et
je trouve scandaleux qu'on ne parle pas
du dopage dans le foot à leur insu ou
pas ils sont dopés après mon enquête
il vrai journaliste
il faut dire que décide à faire un livre
sur william gallas jpack i les dopés
d'ailleurs je d'ailleurs je n'en ai
jamais parlé avec lui mais du coup j'en
ai parlé avec beaucoup de personnes du
milieu et qui m'ont dit surtout ne
l'écrivez pas mais voilà et je peux vous
dire at-elle match ceux ci existent
voilà donc c'est quand même scandaleux
de faire autant sur le dopage dans le
cyclisme mais que fait-on du foot
pourquoi parce qu'il ya trop d'argent
pourquoi vous raconter aussi la cocaïne
j'adore ça c'est ça m'intéresse beaucoup
bien
mais c'est du passé je dis ça aussi mais
vous aussi le centre repenti finalement
vous parlez du tour de colombie en 84
vous raconter qu'ils avaient des
suiveurs caves et des kilos de coke dans
le coffre de la voiture quand même je
mette au vélo moi c'est fini je pense
c'est l'époque des narcotrafiquants
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est
important et l'info trafic en aimait
beaucoup le vélo le vélo était très
supporter en colombie par ces gens là
michel drucker ou pas et qu'ils quoi
quand il fait une chute initiale je suis
sûr qu on apprend des trucs j'ai roulé
avec michel et je peux vous dire que non
ça fait pas stoppé la non non il monte
devant nous il a trop doucement mauricie
ce qui est bizarre c'est finalement avec
toute cette drogue dans le cycle in les
jeunes ne sont pas spécialement attiré
par ça
sérieusement quand vous commenter le
tour de france pour france 2 comment
vous pouvez continuer à admirer ces gens
là alors que vous savez qu'en fait ils
sont un peu aidé moi quand je commande
je suis plutôt du côté
technicien donc j'explique ce que vous
voyez à l'antenne et c'est de vous dire
pourquoi ça roule vite pourquoi ça roule
pas vite quelle tactique il peut y avoir
après effectivement de temps en temps il
ya des choses qui me semblent un peu
bizarre mais je peux pas non plus
prendre position définitive je ne sais
pas vraiment ça fait comme disant qu'ils
aient pas eu un vainqueur du tour autour
duquel il est pas eu des rumeurs et
soupçons ou des condamnations et ça je
le dis encore une fois en amoureux du
tour c'est quand même très perturbé 6e
quand tu vois passer armstrong qui monte
l'aubisque à 75 km à l'heure mais il ya
un truc sans transpirer escompté
respirait pas une fois il faut celle ci
vient largement en mesure de faire suivi
une étape contre la montre du tour notre
fribourg et mulhouse et j'étais derrière
l'allemand sap et nouveau riche ulrich
et alors il a foncé pendant soixante-dix
mètres sans se relever sans respirer et
c'est comme une flèche si j'arrive et
puis l'été ce bond jusqu'à l'épreuve a
été plus vite
mais en fait ça n'empêche pas les gens
de regarder le tour de france
heureusement non mais c'est bizarre
comme ils savent que les mecs sont un
peu aidé quoi ça change rien de l'effort
l'effort est toujours le même mais sur
un peu plus vite si on a l'air on a
l'impression que c'est un peu trafiqué
les forêts toujours le même vous êtes
tous invités sur un vélo vous avez
comment c'était dur pour aller vite
c'est rouler vite qui est dur en vélo
alors christine le csa lac est tellement
soucieux qu'on confirme pas à l'écran
qu'on boive pas de champagne à l'écran
mais quand vous voyez le tour de france
vous dit rien c'est ça la non mais quand
je vois je vois le tour de france
personnellement là je parle à titre
personnel je suis très surprise par les
marques qui a pas voilà un tiens quand
je reviens de roland garros idem quand
je regarde france à la voile idem et
justement j'enquête pons amant et ouais
autant de marques qui appareils servent
pas sûr qu'ils sont tombés dans les
mains la bravo
voilà donc vous apprêtiez à sortir ce
livre qui je le dis vraiment passionnant
et là vous avez appris le 20 mars que
vous aviez le le cancer quoi c'était un
cancer des voies digestives voilà tout
ce que l'on sait donc pourrait
semblablement plutôt estomac pancréas ça
change pas grand chose finalement il
faut le battre c'est nier que ce soit
des spectacles autant que sa valeur en
soi même ce serait mieux vous serez
fixés quand là dessus sur cette paie
peut-être jamais il ya un ou deux
pourcent de cac où on ne le retrouve
jamais un défaut on ne trouve pas mais
je savais pas quelque chose qui arrive
ça empêche pas de guérir oui bon vous
cette façon logique fait de la chimio
les ganglions déjà diminué de moitié à
peu près peu après deux séances oui
après ocean race est sur la bonne voie
est-ce que vous pensez que ce cancer est
dû à tous que vous avez pris à l'époque
ou non rock non je crois absolument pas
je dis pas simplement ça comme ça à la
limite il vaudrait peut-être mieux pour
les générations futures vous préféreriez
vous que ce soit dû à ça non
peu importe ceci dit moi ça m'est égal
et là je l' ai donc je ne peux pas faire
autrement mais je crois vraiment pas
alors vous avez décidé de vous battre
vous dites je vais faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour pas y passer c'est bien mais
j'ai déjà commencé bien sûr j'ai changé
mon alimentation bien sûr un problème
mode de vie vous dit j'ai pas peur de
mourir j'ai eu une belle vie jusqu'à
maintenant on se bat aujourd'hui c'est
vrai quand on m'a annoncé sa forcément
c'est la première chose à laquelle on
pense puisque c'est une maladie mortelle
et puis je me suis dit mais moi ça me
fait pas peur
alors est ce que c'est parce que
justement j'ai eu une belle vie c'est
vrai que la reine d'ailleurs le livre
parle de tout ça on l'avait pages avant
toutes ces choses là
bon peut-être que c'est ça je sais pas
mais j'ai pas envie par contre j'ai
vraiment pas envie lundi soir il a gagné
le tour de france une fois après le
concert 7 cette fois
je vais essayer non je veux dire qu'on
sent qu'on peut s'en sortir oui oui bien
sûr il ya beaucoup plus de guérison
qu'on le croit alors on a reçu beaucoup
de beaucoup de mails de gens ni nous
disant il dit à fignon de rester avec
nous parce que va pas se retrouver avec
virin que commente en le
commentant le tour sur france
télévisions voilà où ça ya beaucoup de
gens qui comme ça je vous faire plaisir
faites nous plaisir rester avec nous
tous les cas vous avez l'air d'avoir la
tête
[Applaudissements]
pour être je crois toute la france est
avec nous a vraiment soit le tout le
monde vous tout le monde vous soutient
vos supports aussi beaucoup de messages
de sympathie bien sûr ça m'a fait très
peur je peux pas répondre à tout le
monde mais je remercie tout le monde
courage camarades
bien voilà c'était salut les terriens
les pierre moscovici
député du doubs
justin kelly membre du csa
alexis brézet directeur de la rédaction
du figaro magazine hello clients pour
cent
section jeunesse solution chez grasset
voilà alors on se retrouve dans 15 jours
avec les imbattables jeu la saison 3 la
semaine prochaine si wimbledon je vous
laisse avec le sav des émissions et
groland magzine
et puis je voudrais profiter de la
circonstance et cette dernière émission
pour remercier tous les gens qui n'ont
et des 30 années à faire cette émission
que j'ai fait vraiment pas tous âges
rassurez vous j'ai remercié les équipes
de télé paris et son directeur stéphane
simon et qui remercie aussi l'équipe
d'ardisson est miné ap les équipes de
canal plus merci à tous de votre page ça
s'est bien passé je vous y est pour
quelque chose merci rendez vous
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu